the world's getting hotter and it's not
global warming it's political tension
driven by emotion
now we worry if civility is dead well is
it the good news most of America isn't
what's on TV
the shouting on camera is what attracts
the camera in the first place so you see
more of it however it may not be a bad
idea to lower the temperature why not a
peace movement or at least a keep the
peace movement to kick it off let's
admit one key truth almost all people
who disagree with each other think that
they're the good guys a smart man Norma
Donald once tweeted today actually the
idiot sees the world as good versus evil
the cynic sees the world as evil versus
evil the truth that no one seems able to
see is that the world is and has always
been a battle of good versus good so
everyone who annoys you they think
they're right but so do you and that
annoys them the solution understand
first that we live our lives with
different filters and these filters
clash still we all want the same thing
and that's good healthy lives for us and
everyone direct during Hurricane Harvey
we saw deplorable and non deplorable 'aa
like saving lives so what if we looked
at this current political climate as a
natural event and lent a hand so what
are you doing hard times you help you
compromise and when possible you always
forgive isn't it a time for a peace
movement begun by conservatives after
all you're the guys in charge now you
may not get anything in return if
someone thinks you're evil all you can
do through your actions is prove them
wrong if it doesn't work at least you
know that you have done right rather
than simply be right boom hey so well I
want to get to you first I believe that
if we were going to create some kind of
reduction in hostilities it's got to
come from conservatives because you
can't expect it from the people who are
out of power when you are out of
power it is almost natural not to play
nice because you are upset that you're
out of power so it's more like the
responsibility of the people
conservative supporters of Trump to
extend the hand does that make sense
yeah in fact I'm sort of thrilled that
you would say this I'm really I really
appreciate it because it seems to me
that there's so much animosity in the
air and everybody is throwing something
that's beyond spitballs at each other at
this point and suspect of their motives
so listening to what you said about nor
McDonald saying it's good versus good I
was like hey you know sometimes I think
people who don't have good in mind
simply want to line their pockets or
want more power for themselves or trying
to advantage their friends are doing
business obviously at the moment I have
very strong feelings about separating
children from families yeah right so I
mean I I'm not going to deny those
feelings and I don't want to be shut up
and expressing my feelings but I do
think that we are out of control in
terms of the mockery the bullying the
kind of attitude that says you know what
you're not worthy you're not an American
if you're not playing with my team
mm-hmm you know Jessie the
counter-argument to this is that screw
civility they've made politics personal
so now it's our turn how do you get out
of that thing where you go like okay I'm
willing to be civil even if you aren't
and it could go for either side well
it's tough to kind of unilaterally lay
down yes yes politics because it's such
a cutthroat industry it was just what a
year ago when Steve Scalise was shot by
a Bernie bro and everybody around this
table said listen we need to lower the
temperature tone down the rhetoric and
unite as a country and a year later here
we are in the exact same spot where it's
very very vicious and I think both sides
need to tell their own people to chill a
little bit and get back to basics we're
all Americans the thing we did yesterday
with our heritage and we have more in
common than we have different than each
other so that's a good thing but at the
same time there is a difference when
Trump retweets a video of himself body
slamming a CNN logo and some of the
things that have gone on on the Left I
mean it was in the inaugural
at the left firebombed a limousine we've
had black lives matter people chant
death to cops we've had an tyfa smash
store windows hollywood has fantasized
about trump child rape and beheadings
nancy pelosi herself said the tax cuts
were literally going to kill people so i
remember back in the Obama
administration a rodeo clown dressed up
as President Obama and he lost his job
immediately and now a Senate staffer for
a Democratic senator yelled fu to the
President of the United States Donald
Trump as he was passing by and she kept
her job so you know I'm willing to
listen and I'm willing to say when my
side is wrong but the other side needs
to be accountable too and right now
there's a division in the Democratic
Party what are the Trump resistance
tactics going to be you have
establishment politicians like Schumer
and Pelosi who know how to win elections
you know Democrats win when they're
moderate or pretend to be moderate and
they get it and they know when to
condemn but then the activists where the
energy are there okay and they want to
confront people in the street they like
the mob action that excites them and
they're gonna have to struggle with that
internal turmoil all the way through
2020 because right now the division is
on that side and it's getting pretty
ugly
yeah as you know Kimberly I am NOT
practicing religious person but we know
that the christ-like thing is to turn
the other cheek so when Jesse talks
about this side that is more hostile the
reaction should be to turn the other
cheek but do you see that happening when
it gets more eated yeah no I mean you
know it's a very good discussion a
healthy discussion to try to you know
create some kind of unity some civility
you know on both sides I think it's not
helpful to finger point and say well
they're worse than this side etc I'm
like everyone has to accept their own
personal responsibility for their
discourse their rhetoric their conduct
everyone including the president United
States and then you know we lead
individually by example but you know
what I don't like is the the threats of
violence to have people harmed physical
you know violence or turning away
families
they can't eat at a place or things like
that is just taking it you know too far
it's okay to have you know healthy
discussions and disagreements about
political philosophy or ideology but
when it comes to making threats like
that a physical harm or showing just
total disrespect you know I just know it
son becoming its conduct unbecoming um
Dana that the bottom this is a in an
eternal conflict that let no one in war
thinks they're the bad guy so if
everyone thinks they're right that
they're the good guys how do you get the
person who thinks they're right to also
see that you might be right
isn't that the answer for this eternal
question I think that it is a lot about
personal relationships remember during
the Obama administration it was always
surprising that he waited so long to
play golf with John Boehner yeah and the
things that when a personal relationship
can do and there was a couple of times I
think that the Democrats came to have
dinner at the White House and things
like that and in this current
administration but turn the other cheek
has become replaced by counterpunching
yeah and it's successful yeah so do I
see it changing not necessarily unless
people realize like whoa we are really
close to unraveling what we have built
and to me civility is a choice so every
time you decide to say something and if
you're privileged to be on television to
have a chance to give your opinions
about something or debate something with
somebody you have a choice in what you
say and I also don't want to be
responsible for other people's words so
policing your own side is there's
something to be said about that but I
also feel like that's a lot of
responsibility yeah it so it does start
with the self the other thing I'd point
out is Selina Zito the columnist who
wrote a great book but not can't
remember but it's about sort of the
trumps America like voting for Trump and
why and she wrote a piece today about
the death of these civil society
organizations we make talked about the
Freemasons the other day things like
that where you had organizations where
people could belong and nobody wants to
really belong to anything anymore except
for to their side right and that leaves
a real dearth of the possibility of
getting people together
one-eye there are a call there are
people that believe calls for civility
are incompatible with free speech it's
like okay you you're whenever I come in
and I March and I my voice is loud
you're caught you're calling that
incivility when in fact free speech
matters when it's in civil I can see
that point like you know it's like you
don't want to hear the loud noises but
that's the only time you listen have but
is that actually allowing for too much
no pretty time I wasn't this is America
I mean you should be a but going to
something like going to somebody's house
no look I mean you have to open and open
your eyes to reality they're people who
want to protest and have a legitimate
grievance which is about children or
some of the other policies of this
administration the question is how do
you handle it I mean you know part of
this has to do with the breakdown of
facts and people say well that's I
didn't hear about that that's not a fact
I'm familiar with and that kind of thing
and so people have to get this straight
to it you know I saw a poll knowing that
we were gonna discuss this and the poll
says that since president Trump's been
in office now 67% I think it's 2/3
including two-thirds of Republicans say
the tone and the civility in the country
has gone down so trumpet I mean he has
to take some responsibility but that
doesn't mean that the left has to then
say oh so since he's doing that and
acting and saying locker up and all that
kinda stuff that we have to behave that
way
I do think their politics involved and I
think there's a calculation you know
when Trump says some of these very
provocative things it stirs up his base
but guess what I think that the
Democrats then and this response to what
jesse was saying the Democrats have to
be smart enough to say yeah you can
express your abuse but we don't want to
feed this attitude on the part of the
right that oh the left is so
condescending and arrogant and my
in-spec I mean you got at some point say
no that's not what we're about it's not
who we are and I think you saw that with
Pelosi and Schumer come out against what
Maxine Waters said and we've seen
instances now recently someone burned a
dead carcass of an animal on a Trump
officials front stoop and chasing Sarah
Sanders Huckabee out of a restaurant or
right following her across the street or
going outside of Stephen Miller's
apartment and she
threatening things and to what you were
saying earlier and you've said this
before
sometimes you assume the other side has
evil intentions yeah in fact they're
either misguided or they just have a
different political philosophy and
president Trump in the beginning I used
to think if anybody could work with
President Trump it's the Democrats and
he showed that I think he went against
Ryan in McConnell and went with Pelosi
and Schumer when it came to daca in the
beginning
he's willing to reach across the aisle
right now just that Gulf seems really
deep as you know dana as a Jewish Native
American I think one of the big mistakes
in civility is labeling people and I
think we noticed that even in the
primaries people calling each other
rhinos and things like that was like a
thing that like the division wasn't just
left or right no the division was within
each separate division and it was
swallow it you know you're gonna have to
accept that being nice didn't work so
this is what we're going to do this is
it's a new world and now we're talking
about that there are dangers of
incivility because it could lead to
possible violence I mean these haven't
gotten violent yet though I would argue
that the burning of the carcass on the
front porch like you're gonna think that
you're being attacked yeah at that point
what do you do like it could spiral out
of control we have such a gift of being
able to live in freedom and with liberty
and justice for all from here in America
that you could you have to work to
preserve it do not lose this chance to
have this really great wonderful country
continue it's true because if you let it
get away from you you know and you see
something is things like spiraling now
and it feels like dangerous times in
terms of just the incendiary rhetoric
the actions there are the violent
protests and you know nobody wins with
that yes I say listen you know if there
was one thing listen yeah other person
has something to say and they deserve to
be heard absolutely